rostros decepcionados y una solicitud
urgente los afganos que trabajaron para
las fuerzas armadas alemanas pidieron
traer a sus familiares que permanecen en
el afganistán controlado por los
talibanes que por distintos motivos no
fueron elegibles para migrar al país
europeo estar separados de sus seres
queridos es siempre más difícil
hace siete meses que vine a alemania
vine solo y no traje a mis hijos conmigo
así que por favor traigan los aquí no
tienen que los cuiden también cuya casa
está pasando pero esta no es la única
preocupación entre estos refugiados
todavía no nos han dado una casa aquí
también denuncian que alemania trate de
una manera los ucranianos y de otra a
los afganos esto nos parece sumamente
deprimente la gente que está en
afganistán debe ser evacuada rápidamente
y si no lo hacemos nosotros mismos hay
que apoyarlos en esto marcus grotjahn un
soldado alemán que fundó una red de
colaboración para ayudar a los miembros
del personal local explicó que este tipo
de situaciones se deben a las trabas
burocráticas que ponen las autoridades
alemán alemania de acento a 6 millones
de ucranianos pero no re acento a 20 mil
afganos cuál es la razón entre tantos
cientos de personas protagonizaron en
berlín un acto de solidaridad hacia los
refugiados con la esperanza de
sensibilizar a los políticos
responsables y darle una mejor calidad
de vida a los más necesitados